في اول انتصار معلن للمحتجين في ايران
شرطه الاخلاق او ما تعرف بشرطه القمع تحل
بقرار رسمي من النظام مقتل شابه الكرديه
مساء ميني على ايديهم جعلت هذا الجهاز ضمن
بنك اهداف المحتجين منذ اليوم الاول
للاحتجاجات من مدينه قم ذات الرمزيه
الدينيه لدى الايرانيين انها المدعي العام
الايراني محمد جعفر منتظر مهام شرطه
الاخلاق مضيفا البرلمان والسلطه القضائيه
في ايران بصدد مراجعه قانون الزاميه
الحجاب وان النتائج ستظهر في غضون اسبوع
او اسبوعين الجهاز موجود منذ ثمانينات
القرن الماضي وكان يتابع ادق تفاصيل
النساء عبر دوريات شبيهه بدوريات التوجيه
قبل ان تاخذ شكلها الجديد تحت اسم ارشاد
اي شرطه الاخلاق في 2005 من رجال اخضر
ونساء يرتدين زيا اسود وفي عام
1988 قرر البرلمان الايراني فرض الجلد 74
جلده على ما اسماه بالصور ثم اضيفت اليها
مؤخرا عقوبه السجن بشهرين وفي عام 96 نفذت
وزاره الداخليه الايرانيه مشروعا اطلق
عليه محاربه الحجاب السيء وبدا في العاصمه
طهران واستمرت هذه الدوريات في نشاطها بعد
ذلك التاريخ مع تغيرات في الشكل ومسميات
ثم اخذت اسم شرطه الاداب في اواخر ايام
الرئيس الاصلاحيه محمد خاتم